we're talking about depression earlier
there's quite a lot of evidence now that
one of the reasons that men's uh men are
not really getting treated for
depression nearly as as well is that the
help men need yeah is completely
different to the help women need when
they are depressed yes so they need a
different solution but quite often it's
it's a solution that's geared towards
women that is then sort of mapped onto
men and it just doesn't work very well
because men need a different thing men
need to feel competent and Powerful as a
result of whatever therapy they do
whereas for women it's more about being
heard and unpacking certain issues and
whatever do you know what I mean I do I
mean I remember yeah I'm a big believer
in in counseling and talking therapies
you know it took things for me to get
quite bad with me where it was just a
loss sort of throws the dice but I
remember the first counseling session I
went for
um the woman who's the therapist sort of
said you know it's okay to feel weak I
was like weak we mentioned the weak word
for why did you mention that I don't
want to feel it no when I was gone you
know within yeah not too long at all I
wanted more you know like the head tilt
in empathy doesn't really work for me so
if I'm talking about sad things that
happen and someone says that must have
been very tough for you and maybe this
is what's wrong with me I don't know
maybe I need to acknowledge it was tough
but that I I would I just need to almost
verbalize what happened because maybe I
don't reflect on it as much so a lot of
the early counseling I did was just sort
of narrativizing things telling the
story of what happened and they go oh
yeah that what that was that was what I
hated about that or that was what made
me angry and eventually I found the
right therapies and it's it's
interesting you know like there are a
lot of blokes that are still resistant
to talking therapies I think they're a
great thing to get you off the floor I
also think having done them for a lot of
years there is a point where and this is
maybe a more blokey take that your past
is just your past and you just got to
suck it up a little bit well you've got
to go through the process first and
that's why I'm a big fan of that stuff
as well yeah the you've got to process
whatever happened but then you've got to
just accept you know that your life was
your life you're moving on and what is
it that you're going to do in the future
I think I think
you might have to go over like dates and
stuff that make you reflect but but yeah
you go all right that's who my parents
were these were their good things they
sort of bad things the idea that you
constantly retelled that story the the
the concept I think for a bloke of
self-pity is an important one the idea
the tiny violin is always there in our
minds am I you know like because we've
had blokes around us that will call it
out often enough and in the book the
very last chapter is I'm talking about
you know is it okay for men to cry in
public and my view is very much that
it's better if we do in private which
sounds really toxic but I you know I
have a good cry regularly but I just
think that that's where I can do it
properly the problem is the process of
there being witnesses to my tears
changes the function of it right and I
and and also I just think men don't cry
as often statistically so when we do do
it we're not match fear so we look
perfect
like it just looks awful it's like this
[__] Hulk like metaphor emphasis
whereas you know I think you know the
women I've known in my life like my mum
could cry and like still fold clothes
you know so there's there's definitely a
different ability there and I think that
male tears hold a different status in
society so Novak Djokovic cried after
the is Wimbledon final defeat right it's
nice to see my son still there still
smiling you know
[Applause]
um
sorry
I love you
thank you for supporting me and I'll
give you a big hug and we can all
love each other thank you
something within him broke and we're
like
that's wonderful yeah this strong
goddess athlete that's got all the way
he's earned this but if he cried like
that after the quarter final we'd be
like okay mate you know yeah it's a bit
much yeah just get back to the locker
room somebody put a towel over his head
and and you could say that that is toxic
or anything but it's always that's
really you know I don't think you can
completely ignore the base reasons why
that emotional impulse exists in the
first place so again it's like yourself
counseling it's working with what is
there in blokes really and what is there
in place is different than the language
of therapy can sometimes seem a bit
alien
foreign